it's going to be cal quantum he will be
on the mound for the indians he's uh
he's coming off a start against tampa
where he it was an outstanding start he
went six innings gave up four hits now
the one-two
and a wave at it and he was badly fooled
on a slider away kind of a half swing
cointreau with a strikeout his first and
the payoff pitch
got him came back with a fastball that
time nick the outside corner
adam wainwright going tonight for st
louis this is his first career
appearance
at progressive field
and this team record 33rd venue he's
pitched in
the 2-1 right field carlson is there to
make the catch two away last seven ten
games certainly since the break
especially the outfield defense
especially bader but all of them all
that the the trio these three
outfielders have really played well
defensively he's got a huge differential
holmen road
the 1-2 pitch right down the middle and
he struck him out outfield is fairly
deep for bader who's been red hot lately
really pleasant night for baseball
next pitch is hit hard down the right
field line long way to run by johnson he
looks up and
it is gone a home run for harrison bader
harrison bader just stopped at second
base and now he's told nope you get to
go the rest of the way so bader rounds
third on a ball that just snuck over the
wall in right field
bader hits his ninth celebrates at home
plate and the cardinals lead one nothing
95 mile an hour fastball on the outer
half and he gave it a ride
just over the right field wall it hit
over the wall and bounced back somehow
hit in the seats and the ball went down
and maybe hit the ground hit a wall and
bounced back the one two
and strength three called
carpenter thought it was high he's
strength on victim number four yeah
that's crazy interesting it is more
interesting
strike three called hitting over fifth k
for cuantro but the cardinals strike
first
off the end of the bat but he punches it
into left field for a base hit kept the
hands back beautifully
he must have been looking for that for
the very first pitch
jose ramirez
all 20 of his home runs have been to the
pool side
high fly ball deep right field goodbye
jose ramirez puts the indians on top 2-1
he turned that 3-1 pitch right around
for his 21st home run of the season
guess what he got him with the fastball
the first time up
jose got him the second time up with a
3-1 fastball and he didn't miss it
wednesday took a no decision
the cardinals won that game three two
and ten swing and a miss
and strikeout number four for wainwright
got him
tails back in catches the top of the
strike zone back-to-back k's and five
tonight for adam wainwright
3-0 pitch and they turn him loose and
it's a fair ball on 3-0
they turn vader loose he hits it down
into the corner bobbled a bit by harold
ramirez and a double for harrison bader
he's got a home run and now a double
and he has the only two hits for the
cardinals tonight
why not turn him loose
what's this sling
the 1-0 pitch is a weak round ball cesar
will have to charge
but he'll throw him out and that's the
inning
we are halfway through
cleveland two st louis one
carlson he swings and smokes it into
center a base hit for carlson
he took a page right out of cleveland's
book right there first pitch swinging
runner it first and one
down
and that's a base hit out to left
back-to-back singles for st louis
carlson now in scoring position and it
brings in nolan aronado
bases are loaded the first walk issued
by quantrill cuantro is ready and the
0-1 pitch to o'neill
swung on a little topper out to the
mound shovel to the plate by cuantro for
the out oh is that huge i mean a little
topper that was 30 feet
out in front of the plate cuantro
charging glove
swooped it from his glove to home plate
and now trainer jeff desjardins going
out to check on cuantro
so they get the force at the plate bases
stay loaded as carlson is forced out at
the plate
left field deep back goes big harold and
he runs it down
great job by cal quantrill
gets out of a bases loaded one out jam
without allowing a run see if they want
to start the runner here a little bigger
lead this time for ramirez he is running
strike him out throw him out it's a
double play
forget the sinker ground ball double
play he goes uncle charlie and yadier
molina does his thing to
just hammer down jose ramirez
swing and a miss strikeout number seven
for wainwright that is a big double play
and maybe a little momentum shifting
double play
that's in the gap long run for zimmer
can't get it
[Applause]
backed up by johnson edmonds going to
turn and burn and now he jams on the
brakes and now he's going for third and
the throw to thirds in time and they got
him
oh
my goodness
the old stop and start
gets another would be base runner trying
to advance
i don't know what happened to ahmed
rosario the ball hit him right square in
the glove but it popped out and when
edmond saw that he thought i can get to
third
carpenter with a base hit into center
two out hit
cardinals running out of time feels like
the game's moving along a little too
quickly here as we play in the seventh
inning cardinals trailing by one brondon
the runner at first base the young at
the plate
and a young
cranks one out to deep left a hanging
breaking ball
gone
the shortstop comes through
and the cardinals
needed that in the worst way and they
get a two-run bomb from
paul to young
and it's 3-2
st louis
i try to do the same thing again down
almost hit him throw down to third got
him and vader's saying no
there's a swipe tag and i'm not sure
they got him
well they ever got him right there maybe
but by that time the hand is in vampires
are set looks like with the call we'll
see
and by that reaction he is safe how
about that
3-0 pitch
and he walked him he walks in a run to
make it 4-2 cardinals
three consecutive walks the one
fly ball center field who else baiter
there
makes the catch cardinals take game one
of the series
4-2 the final